it's been just three weeks
just three weeks
since we lost her majesty the queen
as we Face new challenges without her
we would do well to keep her in our
thoughts
history after all is experience
remember that she became Our Queen just
seven years after the bloodiest conflict
Humanity had ever seen
we were a nation facing debt hardship
rationing
and the daunting task of modernizing in
the Twilight of Empire
it was said of the King's death
that Britain had lost its balance wheel
that's part of a watch which moves the
hands forward
which keeps the beat
which keeps things steady
the world witnessed a young woman pale
with grief pledge her whole life
to our nation's service
doubt and despair
gave way to Hope
her pledge turned out to be a shining
gift to the world
she saw us through change and challenge
constitutional crisis conflict
covered
and every time we battled we had her
majesty alongside us
advising us
guiding us
unifying us all
and reminding us of the challenges we'd
face together in her long life many much
greater than we face now
her gift
was calmness
confidence
courage
she enabled us to stay the course
and she gave us a common Bond and a
common goal between us all between
nations Beyond politics
for prosperity
for security for Unity
for a United Kingdom
no words of mine
can do justice to the depth of her
Devotion to us
she sacrificed her time
her freedom
her private life
and her passing was felt deeply
in every place on Earth
because it reminded us of our own grief
for loved ones
we'd lost
because
she had shared her family
with us
you see
crowns are not made of precious metals
and jewels alone
they are mostly made
of Duty and love
so when she died we carried her on a
river of love from Balmoral to her final
resting place at Windsor
its tributaries weren't just pageantry
they were personal
that were the gods of Honor from tractor
drivers and horse riders
there were the crowned drawings attached
to railings
and carpets of flowers
and an enormous amount of cling wraps
marmalade sandwiches
and prayers
and thanks
from every faith
and the ceremony of her church
the state
and her Armed Forces
vigils
and silences in the fading Autumn light
everyone
played their part everyone worked
together that unity and pride and
dignity are things that we will remember
for the rest of our lives it made us
proud
of our Queen and our country
her final gift
was to show us the truth
about her remarkable reign
the Revelation was in her meticulously
planned final appearance
you see
our late Monarch did not stamp her
personality on the nation
she was the one who shaped by us
by all of us
her people
the stoic
dignified
kind
patient
dutiful
cue loving British people
that's why she was the best of us
as we mourned we leaned on our
constitution on our traditions and on
our planning we saw the pride the people
causes and organizations she cherished
and that this nation was the cradle for
many of which were represented in her
funeral procession
and we saw the values
that bind us
because they were embodied in her
and we calmly got on with it
cheerfully facing change and challenge
and we coped really well
an entirely new government was formed
strike action of both the rail dispute
variety and the football variety was
canceled
supply of arms and support for Ukraine
never faltered
we kept calm
and we carried on
because that is what great people and
great Nations do we're not measured in
Triumph we are measured in challenge
and in that final Journey
she brought us together again
she made us realize that Duty and
sacrifice and tolerance and above all
love are everything to the British way
of life
but most of all
we were filled with good wishes for our
new king
he Bears the same cross that she did
that all do that wear the crown
he will be our new balance wheel
he will be by our side in the new
challenges that we face
we will face them together
we should not and we will not be daunted
by them we will remember our duty we
will continue
to move things forward
to keep things steady not to miss a Beat
and to bring hope
do not forget
what she taught us
do not forget
what we must do
not forget
Who We Are
thank you all from the bottom of my
heart
[Applause]